wind bombs are arguably the most famous
technique in breath of the wild to let
you travel massive distances quickly and
with style but just how many ways are
there to win bomb
we've covered several of these in our 33
ways to fly video but you'd be surprised
at just how many more versions and
combinations of this trick have been
created over the years but first let's
quickly recap on what a wind bomb is
remote bombs are not just one explosion
there's two the wind box and the
damaging explosion the invisible wind
box comes out faster than the explosion
so when timed and spaced right objects
will get hit by the wind box first
before the explosion and send objects
flying in case of a wind bomb the wind
box hits the second bomb before the
explosion knocking into link and the
forces multiplied when exiting bullet
time causing a huge launch
so how many ways are there to do this
the basic front hop wind bomb is the
most common one to date triggered by
simply jumping over a cliff edge or high
ground the basic rule is you usually
drop the round bomb first then the
square bomb for consistency but you can
change this order for a different angled
launch
a key part of wind bombing is to place
the bombs in a line to strike link and
to do this during bullet time but you
can also use perfect parries instead of
bullet time to make this work as well
you can perform the rook's front hop
wind bomb by jumping and dropping the
bombs as normal but using the rook's
protection to parry at the exact same
time and you can win bomb yourself using
the power of deruk's parry's slowdown
if you want to head more upwards though
the vertical wind bomb is the way to go
by placing the square bomb and
backflipping and dropping the round bomb
below yourself you can knock yourself
sky high
this can also be done in a very
difficult way again using daruk's
protection by firing a bomb arrow
drawing your sword back flipping then
perfect parrying the explosion this
gives link an angle to launch straight
up into the air
[Music]
turn wind bombing pivots length's body
angle slightly before getting struck by
the bomb while it has many outcomes in
terms of speed and distance it generally
shoots them at a more downward angle as
opposed to a more normal launch which
favors height
aiming wind bomb has the same goal as
the turn wind bombs to change the angle
of your launch to be more horizontal but
because the game can have trouble with
wind bombs with lots of clutter on your
screen to load such as a forest aiming
at the dirt or sky can reduce objects
loaded and make the wind bomb more
successful
delayed wind bombs are a common practice
for changing the angles and speeds of
your wind bombs as well such as a
delayed turn wind bomb or delayed aiming
wind bomb to mix and match for specific
speeds and distances
mid-air wind bombs can also be performed
in several ways one way is to drop one
below you and another quickly behind to
line them up for a nice mid-flight
launch the other way is to be gliding at
full speed and line them up horizontally
this linear mid-air wind bomb will give
you a nice flat angle forwards
spider wind bombs are simply wind bombs
starting from jumping off a wall same
concept as any other normal wind bomb
just using a little upper body strength
first before going for a quick flight
remote bombs are not the only thing that
have wind boxes bomb arrows or any
explosion can launch link just as easily
this can also be done on flat ground
combined with the shield block reset as
well
backflip wind bombs are one of the most
consistent ways to perform a wind bomb
just place the square bomb hop forwards
twice towards a ledge then backflip then
summon your second bomb and explode your
farthest bomb easy
horses and master cycles have a special
dismount animation and can be used to
win bomb directly off your mount
if there's a nice ledge to jump off of
you don't necessarily need to set
yourself up for a wind bomb you can run
or walk win bomb right off the edge
depending on your timing and these both
have different angles and speeds
a nice wind bomb setup is to shield jump
off a rising cryoner's block remove the
shield then wind bomb as normal extra
style points
now i'll bullet hose a couple special
ones that are based all on getting
bullet time on open ground these include
updraft twin bombs
[Music]
jelly bounce wind bombs
shield block reset wind bombs
and shield jump cancel wind bombs
all these require pretty precise timing
and can be extra tricky to pull off
what's your favorite type of win bomb
let us know in the comments below and if
you enjoy breath of the wild still stick
around because we still make videos to
this day for everything else gaming keep
it here on gamespot
[Music]
you